[MUSIC PLAYING]
THERESA PAYTON:
Hello, everybody.
I'm so excited to be
here with you today.
Couple of things--
I want to make sure
we have a dialogue.
Because if all I
do is talk to you
about maybe a few nightmares,
maybe a few scary things,
tell you a few
White House stories
and that's all that happened,
then I only did half my job.
So I want to make
sure that you feel
like you can ask me questions.
And for those of you that
are live streaming in,
your questions are going
to be moderated by Heather.
And we were talking about making
sure everybody's questions get
answered.
We're going to find
a way to do that,
even if we run out
of our time together.
And then for those of
you that are in the room,
your incentive plan
is to ask a question.
And the first one
to ask a question,
you get a signed copy of my
book, which my mother says
is a must read.
And then if you
don't ask questions,
and you're too shy
to ask questions,
then I ask random
people random questions.
So that's your incentive plan
for asking me a question.
I really want to make
sure we have a dialogue.
I'm really honored to
be here with all of you
for those of you who are live
streaming in, those of you who
are here in person.
Google is one of the power
brokers of the world.
And I'm a big fan of Google.
I've also held Google
accountable in talking
about privacy and security,
but I'm a big fan.
As a matter of fact, I power--
our company's infrastructure--
a big part of it
is on the Google Cloud.
So big fan of Google.
And I want to push you
out of your comfort zones.
When I talked to the people
putting on this event,
one of the things
they said is, try out
some new concepts and new ideas,
and I'm going to do that today.
Disagreement is always welcome.
So you don't have
to agree with me.
The only way I'm going
to learn is for people
to share alternative
points of view and ideas.
So your questions can
be anything, any topic,
and feel free to push
back on anything that you
hear me talk about today.
Couple of quick pictures
from the family scrapbook--
so you'll see in the family
photo I've got my two sons--
Keiran and Aidan.
I'm actually seven months
pregnant with my little girl
Maeve there.
And the gentleman next to
me with his arm around me,
that's President Bush.
And the dude next to him--
that's actually my husband.
Then, I have another picture of
the White House press briefing
room podium.
And you can probably tell I'm
actually holding up my son
and ducking behind him.
And I love that
picture because it was
one of those things where my--
I commuted every week
for 2 and 1/2 years.
I don't know if you know
this, but the shelf life
of a political appointee CIO
is roughly 12 to 14 months.
I did it for 2 and 1/2 years.
So that either says I'm crazy,
or determined and stubborn,
or maybe a little bit
of all of the above.
But sometimes, instead
of me commuting,
home my family would
actually come to see me.
And senior staff
really encourage
them to come and
experience the White House
as I experienced it.
And so on this particular day,
actually, the kids were like,
mom, you have the coolest job in
the world, and they were right.
And I still have the
coolest job in the world.
It's just a different job.
But this particular day,
they saw the president land
on the South Lawn in
HMX-1, the helicopter.
Then, they saw the president's
dogs Barney and Miss Beasley.
And Barney was
outfitted with a camera,
so you could see the White House
from Barney's point of view
on Barney Cam.
Then, people were
handing them presidential
M&M's everywhere they went.
And they're like,
this job is amazing.
You help the president
with this computer;
you get to watch helicopters
land, play with dogs,
and eat M&M's-- kind of sounds
like Google, doesn't it?
Right?
And so we went into the
press briefing room,
which is one of the few
places where I could actually
talk about my job.
And we were doing this
major modernization effort
in the press briefing room.
And behind that podium, which
if the president had been there,
there'd actually be
a presidential seal
on the podium, and its nickname
is called the Blue Goose.
But behind that is almost its
own little city of cables,
and wires, and programs running
things from the Blue Goose.
My kids are bored at this point.
So my oldest turns
to me, though,
as we're getting ready
to leave and he says,
Mama, I really want
to tell the news.
And so as I ducked down
so my husband could
take that picture of him telling
the news, it dawned on me,
wouldn't it be great if we let
four-year-olds give the press
briefings in the White House?
I mean, think about the
honesty we would get, right?
And then down at
the bottom, there's
a picture of me in front of one
of the jets in the Air Force
One fleet.
And this is where the job that
you have and the job that I had
are actually not too different.
So if you think about
the White House,
for starters, the
3,000 staff that
work for the executive
office of the president--
they're barely ever
at the White House.
We don't all fit
in the White House.
It was built for a kinder,
gentler, smaller time
in our US government.
They're mobile.
They're global.
They deserve and, in some cases,
demand the latest and greatest
technology.
How do you give them the
latest and greatest technology
to enable them to do
their jobs without--
for me, anyways,
putting a homing beacon
in the president's pocket
was not an ideal thing to do.
For you, it might be a
little different what you're
worried about, but
you're still worried
about the security
and the privacy
in addition to
the functionality.
And so if you think
about it, our jobs
are not too dissimilar, in the
challenges we face every day.
And we're at this really
exciting time in computing.
And Heather and I were talking
about just how amazing it is.
And we don't even know
what quantum computing is
going to bring for all of us.
And it's exciting and
scary at the same time.
And we now have a point
where devices are collecting
and interacting with
each other on our behalf
without human intervention.
It is an amazing
time of innovation.
And the technology that's
being deployed is so cool.
So I don't know
about you, when you
think about commercial
travel and you
think about elegant,
classy service,
do you think flying on
airlines these days?
Maybe?
Maybe not?
Probably not.
I mean, I think Air Force One,
but I don't fly on that as much
anymore.
And so I think kind a the
second best is Virgin Airlines.
I think they do a pretty
good job, whether you're
in first class or in coach.
And so how do they do that?
And I looked into what
Virgin Airlines was doing.
The first thing
they did was they've
outfitted every plane with
Internet of Things devices
from nose to tail, wing to
wing, inside and outside.
Now that's not to say,
well, they're flying.
They're all communicate
with the internet.
But the devices are
collecting information,
and that information is used
to think about safer flying,
are there mechanical issues?
More economical
flying-- so how do
I give you elegant classy
service while having
it be economical
at the same time
and being on time--
so on-time records.
How much data are
they collecting?
One plane, one flight is
a half a terabyte of data.
Now I know this group knows what
a half a terabyte of data is,
but if your mom and
dad ask you what it is,
it's the equivalent
of binge watching 250
hours of your favorite shows--
one plane, one flight,
Virgin Airlines.
That is a massive
amount of data,
but it's really cool
how it's being used.
Now in some cases, where
we're headed with technology
can even save lives.
So in the UK, they actually
have Internet of Things lamps.
And these lamps actually
detect glass breaking, yelling,
banging, loud
noises, and the lamps
actually glow
brighter and brighter.
In some cases, a
camera will turn on,
and they can deploy physical
security if they need to.
These are really cool and
interesting uses of technology.
And then of course, Google--
not to leave out Google--
we have Google Home at my house.
That was actually the
employee gift last year
for Christmas for
everybody in our company.
And everything has to be gold.
That's given as
the employee gift,
so we had to search for
the gold wrappers, which
came later but--
long story about that.
But if you think about
the integration of some
of this technology,
it's almost to the point
where we don't even
realize it's there anymore.
And the opportunity is huge.
When you look at the
economic value for the world,
we're looking at possibly
a $11 trillion dollar
positive impact.
And we've now outnumbers humans
with the number of IoT devices
around the world.
So where do we go from here?
One of the first things I want
to be thinking about since it's
Internet Safety Awareness
Month-- so National Cyber
Security Awareness Month.
It's also International Cyber
And this is the 13th year
that we're doing this.
Do you guys feel safer?
I don't know about you; I don't.
So 13 years in, lucky 13.
First thing I want you
to think about changing
is, how many of you have
heard the conventional wisdom
that the human is the
weakest link in security?
So we all say it.
We all say it.
I want to change the dialogue.
So I want to push back
on everybody here and ask
you to question why do we
still, after over a decade,
rely on the human and say
they're the weakest link?
Maybe, just maybe, I'll
push this idea out to you--
that maybe given
the hockey sticks
we have in cybercrime,
that maybe given
the geopolitics of
the world-- and I
don't know about you if
you're a history buff,
it's never felt
more tense than it
has for me based
on what I've read
of ancient history
and modern history.
It feels pretty tense to me.
Maybe it's because
I'm living in it.
we're all living in it.
It feels more intense to us than
maybe World War I, or World War
II, or the Cold War, right?
But maybe we should be thinking
about, no, the weakest link
is actually us.
I started off as a developer.
Maybe there is a
moral imperative
that when we talk about
feature and functionality,
the first thing we
should be talking about
is, let's not depend on the
weakest link, the human.
So I'm going to push that out
as something I want each of you
to consider--
is we need to change
that dialogue.
Because if we keep
relying on the human,
we're going to keep failing,
and we can't afford to fail.
Cyber criminals have never been
more organized, more talented,
and, in some cases,
more scalable.
So we're seeing the attacks
cost a lot of money.
So you don't even have
to be technical anymore.
You can buy your way
into attacking companies.
And so it all
starts with designs.
I really want to push
hard on this concept of,
how do we think
differently about design?
And maybe some of it starts with
thinking about ethical hacking.
So before you even build
that piece of functionality,
maybe you bring the
ethical hacker in--
not for them to
throw a wet blanket
on your fire on the
great idea that you're
trying to innovate but
to turn to them and say,
so how would you break this?
Before I even build it,
how would you break it?
How would you take advantage
of the human that's using it?
How do we not be reliant
upon the human that's
the weakest link?
And for me, I have to tell
you, one of my tipping
points when I first got
to the White House--
you know, I used to work in the
financial services industry.
And so every time
bad things would
happen in the financial
services industry,
I'd think to myself, if I
could just get to every user.
If I could just talk to
you for a little bit,
and train you a
little bit better,
and write the policies
a little bit better,
life would be so much better.
And that's all it is.
It's communications.
It's training.
We just got to do this better.
And when I got to
the White House
and I realized,
OK wait a minute,
OK, there's 3,000 people here.
They're global.
They're mobile-- just like
our banking customers were,
so I didn't think that
was too different.
But the threats that were
targeting the White House
were ever-changing.
And I thought, if I'm
going to try and brief
everybody every day on what
I'm learning as different
and I'm going to hold down
accountable for understanding
how to protect themselves,
I'm going to fail.
And that's when I realized
I wasn't always designing
for the human.
And I'll talk to
you in a little bit
about how to think
about designing
for the human in one of my aha
moments at the White House.
But I've had a second
aha moment lately.
And this really happened
to me in the last year,
and it really came to the
forefront with the discussion
around the election cycle--
not just in the US but over
in Europe--
and the potential for Russia,
possibly other countries,
to use propaganda to change
people's minds and opinions
and potentially have them
change how they vote.
And that domain is we
were so focused on, OK,
the humans the weakest link.
And we need to
protect the servers.
And we need to protect the data.
And we need to
protect the devices
that we forgot to protect
crowdsourcing and crowd
thinking.
And so in that effort to be
thinking about, how do we
reach people, and how do
we stay interconnected,
and how do we get
information in a way
that we want to receive
it that's the most
beneficial to us in that moment
that we receive it-- so if you
order something on
Amazon, it tells you
what other people who
ordered that ordered.
And a lot of times you
think, that's pretty cool.
I probably need that too.
And that's helpful.
But at the same time, as
that technology matured,
it also created unintended
echo chambers, which
I'll talk about in a moment.
But I want you to be thinking
about the domain of security
has now added a new domain.
So it's not just data.
It's not just devices.
It's not just the humans.
But it's actually the
social media content as well
that needs to be protected.
And if you read a
security briefing,
I don't know how many of you
have the soul-crushing pleasure
of reading security
reports on a regular basis,
but they all pretty
much sound like this.
The sky is falling.
Data is at risk.
Attacks are worsening.
And the silly user--
it's their problem.
They pretty much
all sound that way.
And I'm going to show you
a couple clips from Hunted
to show you why it's really
not something that the user can
always prevent.
And so what you're going
to see in this first clip--
and a couple of caveats.
On Hunted, when you see the
command center, none of us
are actors and actresses.
We're just working cases.
We're trying to forget
the cameras are there.
It's not scripted.
And so everything
you see that we're
doing-- if we're trying
to hack into an account
or get information,
it's all in real time.
So in this first one,
I'll show you the video,
and then I'll explain
to you what's going on.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- In an effort to gain concrete
intel on David and Emily's
whereabouts, former NSA
analyst Landon Stewart
attempts to break into
David's online accounts.
Windecher@gmail.com.
- I'm going to get
into his Gmail.
Let's mess this lumberjack up.
When a fugitive goes on
the run, my first thing,
because I'm a cyber
guy, I want to know how
to leverage technology
against then.
One of the security
questions for a reset
is his favorite sports team.
So what is his favorite
sports team, Charles?
- Let me see here.
Ah, I'm on his Instagram.
- All right.
- Which sport, though?
Lakers?
He's sitting at
the Atlanta Braves,
but that's probably
the most favorite.
- The Miami Heat.
- Those photos of
him in a Heat jersey.
- He's from Miami, right?
- Miami Heat-- that
would be my bet.
My only concern is--
let's do our best
not to lock him out.
- That's why I want
to have it verified
by more than one source.
- Oh, of course.
- You guys are saying Heat, too?
- Yeah, he's at the
game three weeks ago.
- Let me see.
Screw it.
Let's try it.
We got it.
It's the Heat.
- Oh, you rock.
Last security question.
When did you create
this Google account?
[SIGH] Tough.
- OK, let's try to
be smart about it.
Let me Google the account and
see about when it appears.
Just give me a second.
- Yeah.
- Let me see here.
Here is the oldest one I see.
It's January of 2014.
It might be the
best shot you got.
This is a crude way of doing
it, but it's the best one I got.
- It could be that one,
but that's no guarantee.
Oh my God.
It worked.
We've got all his contacts,
we have everybody.
- Dude, that's awesome.
[END OF VIDEO PLAYBACK]
THERESA PAYTON: OK
so a couple of things
about what you just saw there.
First of all, whenever we heard
that the fugitives had a Google
account, we would just groan.
Because we're like, oh,
based on Google security--
and privacy settings, they're
the hardest ones to get into.
And so we'd actually
have to file--
I'd have to send a written
thing to a judge I never
got to meet with who always said
no to pretty much everything.
So I would always
have to justify
what our techniques were in
the cyber and intel group,
and I finally got a yes.
David Windecher used
to be a criminal.
He's now a defense attorney.
He was a formidable
opponent as a fugitive
on the run-- just really, really
smart at what he was doing.
And we had actually
recovered his laptop
from the scene at which he fled.
But he had logged
out of his account--
didn't have two-factor
authentication on.
And so we finally got
the OK from the judge
to hack into the account.
And we knew if we messed up
those questions too many times,
we knew we would be locked out.
And the judge said
we'd be on our own.
And those clues
were critical to us.
I won't give you
a spoiler alert,
but they were
critical to the case.
Oh, and by the way--
Landon, who also
works for my company--
I joked with him-- he's the only
one that throughout the show
would get subtitles, and it's
because he's from Pittsburgh.
And so I'm like, I guess
because you speak Pittsburgh,
they have to do subtitles for
you and not everybody else.
All right, so we'll
go to the next video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I'm going to
assign this to Steve.
- Former Naval Intelligence
Officer Steve Masterson
begins to build a profile
on Troy and Chele.
- Crosscheck public records--
who are they?
What do they do?
- They've been married.
They're high school sweethearts.
They seem to be best friends.
I don't think they're
going to separate at all.
- So they obviously can
stand long hours together.
- Yep.
- Kids?
- No kids.
- OK.
[END OF VIDEO PLAYBACK]
THERESA PAYTON: So in this
particular one, again,
just from a-- and realize
the bad guys do this,
too, to your customers, right?
So we were trying to
figure out Troy and Chele.
I had the suspicion they
were hiding out in the swamp.
They actually had
an airsoft business.
They had done a lot
of camping as part
of their airsoft business,
and the airsoft community
was not talking us.
And that's their
friends and family--
was the airsoft community.
So we were trying to figure
out from a social media profile
like, do they have kids?
Would the kids be a clue?
No kids.
But we did find out they had a
pet who meant a lot to Chele.
And so we had a lot
of rules of things
we couldn't do to lure people.
But one of the
things I wanted to do
is just have the vet call
Chele's mom just to check in
and to see when Chele was
going to check in on the pet--
not to say the pet
was sick-- because I'm
a pet lover myself--
or anything.
And at that point,
I was told, I know
it's not written in
the rules, but you're
a really cold person, and we're
writting it into the rules
that you can't talk about pets.
So anyways, pets were
taken off the table.
But you can see how just
using a social media profile,
we were trying to get a feel
for where they would be.
They had 800,000 square miles
they were allowed to hide in.
And just by studying
them on airsoft,
I knew they weren't going--
they were airsoft
enthusiasts, looking
at their airsoft websites
that they would participate in
as well as-- the two of them
got along so well, most likely,
they weren't going to argue.
They were going to be a good
support network for each other.
All right, one more video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Back at Command Center,
the cyber team's Facebook
wanted poster is widening
the circle of associates
for fugitives Troy and Chele.
- Guys, don't pay
attention to this post.
It is not Chele posting.
Snitches get stitches.
JD-- it says,
snitches get stitches.
So I want to figure
out who your JD is.
- I love the results of what's
happening on this Facebook
wanted poster.
We're getting new names and
contacts we didn't have access
to before.
It's incredibly helpful.
[END OF VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- So in this particular
one, again, the community
was not talking to us, and so
we got permission from the judge
to actually flip
their social media
profile to a wanted poster.
And I knew that they
weren't going to--
nobody was going
to turn them in.
I knew that.
But what I knew was whoever
seemed to defend them
the most was probably
somebody I wanted
to put under surveillance.
And that actually
ended up helping us
out a lot in that case is
somebody who spoke up a lot
and told people
not to talk to us
and not to help-- we
actually went to her house,
and we actually ended
up, in 24 hours,
apprehending them with the tips.
And nobody outed
them, but it was just
the way people behaved on social
media gave us a clue that they
might be their lifeline.
And so what does that mean?
So we still have-- not only do
we have sort of this new brave
world of social engineering
where it's never been easier
to do for the bad guys, but
we've got these old school
breaches that are coming
up in the headlines,
whether it's WannaCry,
Petya, NotPetya,
the SEC Edgar
database, Equifax--
and I'm not picking
on these companies.
I mean, the way I
look at it is, they're
a victim of a cyber crime.
You may like what they
did before and after;
and how they handled the breach,
you may agree or disagree,
but they are victims of a crime.
But we've got these
new school problems
to deal with now, right?
So we've got
misinformation, we've
got the social
engineering, and what
I call covert crowdsourcing--
so trying to get people
into those echo chambers on
the different social media
platforms and trying
to incite basically
either positive or negative
emotions around certain topics.
And then we also have this
misplaced faith in technology.
So I don't know how
many of you spend time
in security operations center.
I've spent more
hours than I care to
in security operations center.
I know Heather as well.
And so these
statistics are pretty
staggering given
the amount of money
we have spent on
security technology.
So let's kind of just peel
back a little bit on these.
56% of all alerts that go into
a security operations center
are investigated, which
means that 44% are not even
looked at at all because there's
just not enough time and talent
to be able to run those down.
And of those 56% alerts that
were actually looked at,
only 28% are deemed legitimate.
So the rest are just noise.
72% are just noise.
And then out of that smaller
subset now-- so remember,
we went from 56% to 28%.
So out of that 28%, only 46% of
those actually get remediated.
Do we wonder why we have
the data breaches we do?
Do we wonder why
our infrastructure,
our cybersecurity resiliency
for companies is at risk?
Do we wonder why
it's time to start
naming the human something else
other than, they're the weakest
link?
We have to change
how we focus on this.
Case in point, the elections.
That better have been
our tsunami warning.
I feel like a lot of times, the
data breaches that we have--
we get excited
about it-- sort of
like waking up really early in
the morning to go do something,
and then somebody
hits the snooze alarm
and goes back to sleep.
We're all out of snooze alarms.
And if Equifax
didn't do it for you,
the early warning signs--
that tsunami bell going off
with the elections
absolutely should.
Because it's not
just in America.
It's in other places.
So let's talk about my point
of view on how I look at this.
And I welcome any
questions, comments
on this during the Q&A portion.
So I look at this in
kind of three components.
And the first one being is the
voter registration databases.
We know for a fact that those
were targeted by hackers.
We know that the
state of Illinois
had to take their voter
registration database
offline for weeks
during the summer
leading up to the
presidential election cycle,.
They had had an incident, and
they felt the best thing to do
was to take it offline
to remediate the incident
before they came online.
Did that impact anybody's
ability to vote?
I don't know if it did or not.
But I know during those weeks,
getting a voter registration
and if you were
somebody new to Illinois
was not easy to do
while that was down.
So you have the voter
registration databases.
You also have the polling
booths themselves.
Now nobody has said that they
have found evidence of somebody
went in and voted for one
person and, on the back end,
a different person
was voted for.
Nobody has said that yet.
But ethical hackers
at Black Hat this year
said, if I have proximity
and I have time,
I can absolutely do just that.
And you may or may not know
this, but at the state level,
not only does every state get a
chance to do this differently,
the counties and precincts
within those states
may also do it differently.
And up until this
election cycle,
there was a race to go to the
electronic only with no paper
trail for audit.
I don't know about you,
I think that sounds
like a really bad idea.
I think we need a
trust-by-verify process here.
And really smart people
are working on this problem
to make sure, from a voter
registration database
perspective, our
data is more secure,
but this has to be solved
at the state level.
Lots of really smart people are
working on the actual polling
booths themselves
and making sure
that we don't allow proximity
and we don't allow time
because somebody with
motive could do that.
And then the third piece
is what I talked about,
which is our new domain
we need to be worrying
about in security, which
is the whole social media
and our interconnectedness
on the internet domain
that needs to be thought
about differently.
I'm just going to show you
a couple of quick headlines
that have been in
the news recently.
And it's every company.
There is no one
company at fault here,
but this better be
our wake-up call
for how we think about what
happened during this election
cycle.
Now don't get me wrong.
Political espionage
has been around
since they were two
human beings on earth.
So that's recorded history.
We know that propaganda has
been around for all of mankind.
But what happened this
particular cycle, both overseas
and here in America, was being
able to produce propaganda,
to push propaganda, leverage
these social media platforms
that have been
designed to serve me
and to give me things that
help me and assist me,
which means they know my
likes and preferences--
and because they do that,
these social media platforms
were taken advantage of.
And they were able to,
at a speed never seen
before in the history of
pushing political propaganda,
not only push it out but to
be able to see in real time
whether or not they
had an impact on you
and me based on likes, based
on shares, based on posts.
They never had that before.
They didn't know if
it was working or not.
They had to put
boots on the ground,
and they had to see whether
or not their grassroots
campaign was working.
So we have never
seen what was done
at the speed and scale in which
it was done, not only to us,
but the elections
going on overseas.
And Google has recently
come forward and said,
you've done your own
research, and you
are taking this very seriously.
There's actually a proposed law.
And I always say, be careful
about new proposed laws,
because they typically
are not going to stop
bad things from happening.
And in some cases, they're going
to create a situation that's
so expensive for you to comply
with that it kind of loses
the spirit in
which it was meant.
But there is a law around
sort of the safety of ads
in the political
cycle act that's
being looked at on
the Hill right now.
Let's bring it back
to the humans, though.
So if you remember WannaCry,
which was really bad,
especially for the UK.
I was actually in London
the day WannaCry hit.
And what struck me was,
this was different.
Because typically,
ransomware is all about,
how much bitcoin can I
get out of the victim,
and how much havoc can I
wreak on them in the meantime?
This was different.
People showed up for
surgery and were told,
I can't operate on you
today because we're
under a ransomware attack.
People showed up sick and
needing prescriptions,
and they were told, we can't
write you a prescription today.
That, to me, is--
that's where this is not
about how much bitcoin
did these guys get away with.
But at this point, I think
human safety trumps security.
And this is where we have to
be thinking about design a lot
differently.
And so for my Monty
Python fans, this
is where I'm throwing
the holy hand grenade.
Because we've been
doing security wrong,
and we need to fix how
we're focusing on this.
So what are some
lessons learned?
And I don't know if
this, this is actually
a picture of the White
House flower shop.
Isn't it beautiful?
So after all that dark talk,
it's time for a zen moment.
And this is the beautiful
White House flower shop.
Any Downtown Abbey fans--
it's very much like that--
sort of the usher's office
underneath the White
House that keeps
that sense of history,
and protocol, and class,
and elegance.
And I remember when I
went into the White House
and I did my walk
about-- so there's
13 components that
make up the Executive
Office of the President.
And I went into the
White House flower shop,
and it was just so beautiful.
And I noticed that as she
was making these flower
arrangements, they had barcodes
on every single flower.
And she would scan the
flower with the barcode.
She would cut it off and put
in the flower arrangement.
And I thought, well,
that's interesting.
I'm not really sure
what that's all about.
So I go into the kitchen,
and they're getting
ready to make a big dinner.
And I notice that the chicken
breasts, and the pork chops,
and the paper towels--
they're all barcoded.
And before they get
used, they're scanned.
Barcodes are removed, and they
move on and what they're doing.
I'm like, OK, I've read a lot
of Brad Thor novels and Vince
Flynn novels.
I think I know
what's going on here.
It's like to make sure
there's no anthrax
poisoning in everything, right?
So it's not like, with love from
Russia or something like that.
So I go up to somebody
in the usher's office
and I said, what's going
on here with the barcodes?
I think I know.
And he says, what
do you think it is?
And I said, it's to make
sure it's not poisoned.
And he said, no, it
definitely helps with that,
but that's not why.
And I said, OK, oh, I know--
like if Queen Mum were here,
you wouldn't want to run out
of pork chops, right?
That'd be embarrassing.
You can't run to the
closest grocery store
and get pork chops.
So that's what it is.
It's to make sure-- from
a supply chain standpoint?
And he said, well,
it helps with that,
but that's not the reason why.
And I said, well, what is it?
And he said, well, it has
to do with appropriations.
Because you see, whoever's
going to eat that pork chop,
if it's a political dinner
versus an international head
of state visiting, it's a
different bucket of money,
and we have to charge it to
the right bucket of money.
Hey, this is your tax dollars
at work for those of you
who are Americans here, OK?
Not making this up.
And so they had to scan it
against the buckets of money.
So whoever was enjoying
the flower arrangement,
we had to make sure the
right bucket of money
went to pay for those flowers.
So we were doing the
right thing there,
but I ask you, when you think
about the humans and the humans
involved in this, and you
think about the data--
and all data is
not created equal--
so if you think about protecting
data and putting stricter
standards on some and
easier standards on other,
when you compare the
number of chicken breasts
and Baby's-breaths
scanned that day versus
the president's schedule, which
has everyone he's meeting with,
the Secret Service agents down
to the second where he's going
to turn a corner, which
one's more valuable?
President's schedule.
The other thing I want
you to be thinking about,
too, is that in my
walkabouts, I went and met
with one of the
other components.
And one of these
components travel
with the president a lot.
And most of what they did was
not on the classified systems,
but we had a rule that
more than two pieces
of unclassified data, basically,
created a classified situation.
It was just very sensitive.
Everything at the White House
is very sensitive information.
And so as I'm meeting with
them, I said to them--
I was just asking
everybody, is there
anything we do that's
not working for you?
And so I asked
them, I know you're
under a lot of tight
deadlines when you're
on the road with the president.
Is there anything we ask you
to do in the name of security
or in the name of logistics
that makes it hard
for you to do your job?
And they said, sure.
And I said, well,
what do you do?
Because you have these
really tight deadlines.
They said, oh,
it's really simple.
We either take a picture
of it or we print screen
and we take it with us
to foreign countries.
And to which I kind of
like had that moment--
like that
pit-in-your-stomach moment.
And the old me from financial
services who was all about,
it's about training.
It's just about
explaining to you--
wanted to come back to the top.
But the new me who
said, I'm not going
to blame the human anymore.
I'm not going to say the
human's the weakest link.
I'm going to say I am.
These are my designs.
This is our team
doing the development.
I own this.
And so the new me listened.
And the new me said, why
don't we get together
and why don't you show
us what's going on here?
Because I realize I
lost sight of data
because I had a bad design.
And so I want to push back
on you a little bit of--
always be thinking.
It's not just feature
and functionality
from the user experience.
Never lose that.
Always have that at
the front of your mind.
But I need to push
back, and I need to say,
the weakest link is
actually in development.
We need to stop relying
on the human for this.
It's failing us
every single time.
And then the last
thing that I've learned
is you really need
a kill switch.
And so Barbie--
I don't know how
many of you know
about talking
Barbie, but Barbie,
when she first came out--
most of these issues are fixed
that I'm going to talk to you
about-- but when she first came
out, she had computer viruses,
and she also talked
to any Wi-Fi network--
not just your home network but
any that said Barbie in it--
like wicked Barbie,
evil Barbie--
like networks you
shouldn't talk to.
And I was having one
of those moments.
I was the kitchen, and
I heard my little girl
Maeve say to her
older brothers, I
think I'm going to
ask mama for a talking
Barbie for my birthday.
And so my middle one says,
well, how does she work, Maeve?
And she says, well,
according to the commercial,
I will talk to her,
she will listen to me,
and she'll actually answer
me back-- like in real time,
like no pause.
She'll answer me back.
And my oldest one
says, I don't think
mama's going to
let you have that
because I'm assuming she's
probably talking to the cloud.
You're probably talking
to someone in the cloud.
And my middle one says,
yeah, and some rando--
and so if you don't have
millennials in your life--
you know what a rando is, right?
It's random people.
So some rando
who's going to help
the artificial intelligence
interpret everything
you've said to give
you a good answer back.
And she said, yeah,
you're probably right.
I'm going to ask for an
Easy-Bake Oven instead.
But my point in bringing
up Talking Barbie
is, when she had those
computer viruses,
when she was talking to my
Wi-Fi networks she shouldn't
be talking to because you don't
know if they're trusted or not,
you could turn off her
internet connection
and still play with Barbie.
Just like-- I remember reading
when the NEST had a software
glitch and it wasn't
charging the battery--
and so people on the local
news were like, oh my gosh.
It's getting cold.
What am I going to do?
My NEST thermostat's
not working.
And I'm thinking, you do know
you can walk to the furnace
and flip it on, right?
You do know that?
Like, the thermostat's
just a helpful thing?
And so that kill switch
to me is so vitally
important with what's
going on today.
If you think about the incidents
like WannaCry or Equifax--
and the other PC need to
be asking yourself, though,
is, when do I flip a
kill switch, right?
So when do I flip it?
What limited functionality
will be left?
What are the rules of
engagement for this kill switch?
And how do I educate
people to know it's there?
So the next time-- if
somebody says, look,
there's an Internet
of Things botnet--
right, so we were talking
about REAPER last week
or whatever it is, then you
have an easy, seamless way
with your customers, whether
they're your business
customers or your
consumer customers,
to communicate with them,
everything's going to be OK.
Here's the kill switch
in case it's not.
So if you admit all
security's defeatable,
if you think about the
adversarial targeting,
like we did on Hunted-- because
the bad guys do this, too,
if you have this
aggressive offensive
and you're thinking ahead about,
how do I have a kill switch?
How do I design for
you so you're not
having to worry about
this and plan ahead,
you're going to be
so much better off.
So I want to leave you
with some new rules.
And the first one is-- you
probably have never heard
a security person say this,
but I want you to think about
your development--
where you're putting a warm hug
around the user for security.
So where it's almost
like they don't even
have to think about it.
That's my timer to
get into our Q&A here.
New domains to protect-- so it's
not just the data, the devices,
the hardware, the software.
It's also social media,
and then the fact
that there is no
perimeter to secure.
Also, for those of you who are
interested in kind of diversity
in STEM, we do have a
LinkedIn conversation
called "Help A Sister Up."
If you're interested in
it, it's just up there
if you want to reach
out to us that way.
And there's my
contact information.
And with that let's
go to our Q&A session.
HOST: Great.
So for those of you
in the audience,
do you think of your
questions, but we're going
to take a Dory question first.
And that question
is, could you tell
us more about how you became
interested in this kind of work
and your journey into the field?
THERESA PAYTON: Sure.
And this is
something Sarah and I
were talking about
a little bit, which
I say I'm very blessed
that security actually
came and found me.
When I first came out
of graduate school
at University of
Virginia, my vision
was, I was going to work
on cutting-edge technology,
innovative, things that
hadn't been dreamed of yet,
and that's what I
was going to do.
And then I married somebody
who was in the Navy,
and we got stationed in
Jacksonville, Florida.
And I went to work in banking.
And I actually got to be--
I got hired into a group.
They kind of made
a role around me.
And I was able to, in
addition to my day duties
as a programmer
in trouble support
and helping people with
their end-user computing,
I was allowed to work on
innovative technologies.
And in doing that,
for anybody who's
worked with the financial
services industry, when you're
on the leading
edge of technology,
you're on the leading edge
of cybercrime, and money
launderers, and terrorists.
And that's really what
got me kind of passionate
and fired up around
cybersecurity but,
at the same time, creating it
in such a way that you still
love doing business
with the bank
but that we were
fighting on your behalf
to keep the fraudsters
out of your account.
And it really just
cemented, for me,
when I got the opportunity
to work at the White House.
And the briefings-- you know,
the classified briefings-- you
walk into that thinking
you've kind of seen it
all in financial services, and
you walk into these briefings
and realize, I was looking
into a keyhole in a tiny room,
and I had no real idea about the
capabilities of the adversary.
That's when I made my commitment
that however many years I
had left on this earth to work,
that I would use it to fiercely
defend people, and
companies, and the government
and our allies from bad people.
AUDIENCE: Hey--
THERESA PAYTON: Oh,
and you get a book
for asking the first question.
- I haven't even asked it yet,
and I already get the book?
This is so exciting.
Thank you.
So the question actually
relates directly
to the title of your book.
I'm on the federated
identity team here at Google.
So I think a lot about people's
identities on the internet.
And something your demo
tape made me think about
was that a lot of the ways
that when people strengthen
their internet
identity-- like when
we think of the early
days of the internet,
people had very
anonymous identities.
And now, more and
more, especially
with Google products,
we're giving you
a stronger and stronger
presence online.
And on the product
side, we think
of a lot of ways that
can be helpful for you.
And then this video
reminded me that
to people and, particularly,
to law enforcement,
there are a lot of ways that
having a stronger identity
is really great for being
tracked, or censored,
or any of these other really
bad security-related issues.
So I was wondering if you had
any ideas for addressing that
or any examples that
you've seen in your career
where having a stronger
internet identity
can actually make you safer from
something malicious-- maybe not
a valid police investigation
but a not-so-valid police
investigation.
THERESA PAYTON: Yeah, I think--
well, for example, we
have had situations
with mistaken identity where
because of that kind of lack
of clarity around
identity, you've
had people wrongly accused and
having to clear their name--
police knocking at their
door and they're like,
it really wasn't me.
You've got the wrong person.
And so I do think in creating--
what I would say is that I think
there's a lot in the product
development that Google's
doing right on this, which
is you're informing people
on what to opt in and opt out
on on kind of the
identity management,
and I think it can be
a really good thing.
At the same time, it does
create a little bit of a--
I'm in a conundrum
about it myself.
Because when I think about--
especially the generation
coming up, they're
questioning and learning,
and they're treating it all
as a conversation online.
And there's a generation
ahead of them--
maybe multiple generations ahead
of them that once it's written,
it's now almost like
that's a fact about you
versus a conversation
around the dinner table.
And so I worry for people who
want to leverage the internet
to reach out to other people
who don't think like them
to challenge their own
intellectual thought
process on different topics--
that it's going to
be held against them.
And that's unfortunate.
And so that, I think, to me--
that's the conundrum I'm in,
which is, I would like to
see stronger identity online.
I'd like to see
better identity access
management for more
security and privacy based
on opting in opting out.
But at the same time,
I'm hesitant because I'm
worried that in kind of having
that identity that follows you,
you don't get to choose what
people see and don't see.
And that's a conundrum for me.
And I don't actually have a
good answer for you on that
except for, keep pushing.
Keep pushing in your product
design and the developers
around, what are the
long term impacts
on people for things potentially
following their identity?
And can you get a new identity?
Can you decide, like, I've
grown up now, and that's not me.
And can you leave that behind?
And for many of us who are
digital immigrants and not
digital natives-- yeah, I'd like
to think I'm a digital native,
but technically, based
on birth year, I'm not.
But you know, I started
programming in school.
So for me, I think that way.
But when you think about
true digital natives,
there's no on and off the web.
And so for them, that's
what I worry about.
Great question.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
HOST: Great.
And our next question is,
what do you think the--
or what do you see as
the biggest challenge
right now with the
Internet of Things?
- You know what's interesting?
On the Internet of
Things, I've noticed
there tends to be-- in
the security industry,
they're so focused on,
we need to make sure
that that device itself--
that's gotta be secure,
and that's the problem.
And I am actually
pushing back on that
and saying, if you think about--
I had a picture in the
presentation of the Tacoma
Narrows Bridge from the 1940s.
The Tacoma Narrows Bridge,
if you look it up--
it was built out of
concrete and steel--
independently very
strong materials.
We didn't think about the
enterprise architecture enough,
and it literally looked like
a piece of taffy pulling--
thankfully nobody lost
their lives that day,
but the bridge collapsed
under, I think,
40-mile-an-hour winds shears.
And so the Internet of
Things, to me, I think--
the biggest concern for
me is we're so focused on,
how do I get that
component secure.
We're not actually
thinking about,
how is that component part of a
bigger enterprise architecture?
And how do we know when that
component is behaving badly?
Either because a bad guy
took it over or there's
something wrong with it.
And how do we know when
that technology is obsolete?
And because it's so embedded
in what we're doing,
we don't even know it's there.
So kind of another story--
it's not Internet of Things,
but there was a house
where the phone started
dialing a random number several
times a day for six weeks,
and nobody could figure out
why the phone was doing that.
And what they realized
was is the previous owners
had a now not used oil tank.
And technology had been
fitted on the oil tank
that when it went under a
certain level of being full,
it would automatically
dial the oil company, which
is now no longer in business.
Owners changed
hands on the house.
So when the new
owners come in, they
reconnect the line
for the house.
And all of a
sudden, the oil tank
is now calling the now defunct--
and now, that number
belongs to somebody else.
And it took them six
weeks to figure it out.
And everybody can have a
big laugh, but at the time,
people were just like,
I don't understand.
Like, is there a
ghost in this house?
Like what is going on?
And I worry about that for
the Internet of Things--
is that we've had
them so embedded,
that as that technology
becomes obsolete,
are we going to
remember it's there?
They think actually
a lightning strike is
what turned everything back on.
So it's almost like it
rebooted the program.
And so what happens when
we forget they're there?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for your talk.
I work in user experience
for security and privacy.
So I appreciate a
lot of what you said.
What are the top
pieces of advice
you would give a consumer today
to protect themselves online?
- Sure, a couple of things.
One is never use free Wi-Fi.
And it is one of those things--
so I took our intern Stephen
to a coffee shop in Charlotte,
which is a huge banking town.
And I told him,
take your pineapple.
Take your Mac.
I'm going to take my
Pineapple, my Mac,
and I'm going to hack
you and see how you do.
And then, you're going to hack
me back and see how you do.
And because we have this whole
moral ethics code at Fortalice,
where we say, just because you
can doesn't mean you should,
he said to me, ma'am,
how are we going
to make sure we
don't accidentally
hack other people
in the coffee shop?
And I said it's very simple.
What we're going to
do is, we're going
to name our Wi-Fi
hotspot something
nobody would ever connect to.
So we're not going to name
it the coffee shop name,
we're going to name it
something ridiculous.
The first iteration I named it,
and I named it "fake Wi-Fi."
And five people
connected within minutes.
And so people's
traffic were coming by,
and Stephen's getting upset.
And I said, that's
OK, we'll unplug it.
Stephen, I'm going
to let you name it.
So he says no one will ever
connect to this network.
And he calls it, "data stealer."
And 10 people connected.
And so my point in bringing
this up is, it's like,
you have people who--
I know data plans
are really expensive,
and so they're trying to use
free Wi-Fi everywhere they go,
and they don't really realize
that they need to be using
a virtual private network in
addition to using that free
Wi-Fi to help not--
that doesn't block
100% of all bad things,
but it sure helps a ton.
So that would be the first
thing is-- get a really good VPN
that you're really
comfortable with,
use it everywhere you go,
especially when you go overseas
on vacation, because that's a
really popular time for people
to get hit.
Don't use free Wi-Fi; but if
you have to, have that VPN.
I also say segment your life's.
So just like we talked about
network segmentation and data
segmentation really
briefly, segment your life.
Have one email address
that you use with your bank
that you don't
use anywhere else.
Have one with your health care
because health insurance fraud
is really high right now.
Have one ease for sensitive,
confidential e-mails.
I hate email; but
sometimes, the person
on the other end of the line--
the only thing they want to do
is send me this
confidential email,
so I personally, for that, use a
whole different email platform.
Two-factor authentication-- that
is annoying to most consumers.
Just understand that.
They don't like it.
They don't want to do it.
But if you're
somebody who's online
and you've got that particular
email tied to other things,
you need two-factor
authentication.
And then the last
thing would be,
as it relates to any of
the major issues that
are going on in the world and in
this country, do your homework.
Don't allow things that are
posted on your friend's walls
and on your wall.
Don't allow that to create
extreme emotions for you,
whether those are highs or lows.
Do your homework.
Pick out your own
news organizations
that are on both sides
of different arguments.
And don't react to what
you're seeing right now,
and make sure you
do your own homework
so that you can really
think and make up
your own mind for yourself.
So those would be some
of the bigger things
that I would advise.
Yeah, great question.
HOST: Great.
Our next question
is, you mentioned
being cautious of new
laws in this space.
What steps should lawmakers
and/or the government
in general be taking
to keep us safe online,
especially when we consider
WannaCry and the impact
that it had on
the health sector?
THERESA PAYTON: Yeah,
it's a very fair question.
And it's interesting.
If anything actually
gets passed on the Hill--
so that's kind of the
first big one, which is,
they're not getting along.
I don't know if you've noticed.
Not a lot has been
passed in recent years.
But if anything
were to pass given
what's happened in
the past with OPM
with some of the
credit card breaches--
but when you look at Experian,
that's permanent data.
So the last breaches
were a credit card--
you get a new credit card,
basically, after a year,
you should be fine.
Experian, you're never getting
a new mothers maiden name,
social security
number, date of birth.
They can wait 10 years and
that data is still golden
until America, as a
government, figures out
what our new identification
schema is going
to be for the different
parts of your life,
whether it's the IRS or social
security, or whatever it is.
And so I would be
a big fan of seeing
some type of a consumer bill
of rights around data and data
privacy.
But I am hesitant to
push for something
like that because I worry
that by the time it's enacted,
it's out of date.
And then, too, I worry that
well-meaning, well-intended,
but not technical people will
be dictating for companies how
to technically
take care of that.
But if you were to ask
the Hill for anything,
I would ask the Hill for things
that are incentive based.
So for example, I would
love to see companies
that invest in
security and privacy
get an R&D tax credit for that.
How about the fact that
you're being a good citizen,
and you're investing money in
thinking about this problem
differently.
Why not give you a tax
break for doing that?
So why don't we think
instead about sort
of onerous regulatory burdens.
Why don't we think of
incentives and saying,
for companies who
do right by this,
let's give them a break
for designing differently
and designing for the human
instead of designing and saying
the humans the weakest link.
HOST: And we'll take
one more question.
This is, I think,
the most fun one.
What was the most difficult
fugitive strategy to figure out
on Hunted?
Or otherwise, what were some of
the most creative and effective
disappearances?
THERESA PAYTON: Wow,
that's a good gone.
I mean, candidly I'll give
Troy and Chele some real props.
So what you need to
know for those of you--
if you haven't watched the show
yet, you can binge watch it--
and again, my mom says
it's a must-watch show--
but you binge watch
it on CBS on Demand.
And I it's on Hulu and Amazon.
You can download the series.
And one of the things
about Troy and Chele--
well, for you to know
about all the fugitives--
I had no idea what they went
through other than the capture.
And they didn't let me see
it until the show aired.
So I learned with
everybody at home
where people really were and
the near misses that we had.
And so Troy and Chele-- they
were actually in the swamp
for 14 days straight--
canoeing past alligators--
I don't know if you spent any
time in the Florida swamp,
it is not a pretty place to be.
And so I give them total
props for doing that.
And it was really their
friends commenting
on their wanted page that really
kind of helped us figure out
who would be in the local area
that might be helping them.
Another kind of creative
thing that David and Emily
did was David had actually--
in that first hour, they
were given a full hour ahead
of us knowing who they
are to do anything
they want to do to get ready.
But they have to show
they're getting ready
and that they weren't
a prepper in advance.
And one of the
things he did was he
called different people to
have them be lifelines in line
over the course of the 28 days.
And he set up-- basically,
they were three degrees
of separation away from him, and
they did all the coordination
for him.
And so even though we're trying
to surveil him, and his family,
and Emily, and her
family, really, he
had gone way out of
his circle of trust.
And so that made it harder
for us to figure out who--
because you can only surveil
so many people in 28 days
and convince the court--
you have to have just cause to
put people under surveillance
you have to have a really
well-written warrant for that.
So that was another
really good strategy.
And then it's interesting.
The boys-- Will and Miles--
what they basically
did was, they just
lived off of the
kindness of strangers,
which really was going to
work for them until one
of the people who was
helping them out--
the friend-- wanted
to go to a movie,
and they didn't want to leave
the boys alone in the vacation
rental, and so she actually
called her tip line
and turned them in because she
was tired of them hanging out.
So it's like, when
you do [INAUDIBLE]
on the kindness of strangers--
they had no digital footprint.
The only thing I thought was--
when I read their profile,
I said, they're going
to go to the beach.
Because the 100,000
square miles was
the southeast for season one.
So I said, they're
going to go to the beach
because they can blend in.
They're young men.
They're going to
blend in at the beach.
They like to have a good time.
That's a great place to hide.
But there's Myrtle Beach,
and there's Florida beaches,
and there's all
kinds of beaches.
And that really
was their undoing
was living off the
kindness of strangers.
And one of them got tired
of them and turned them in.
HOST: Excellent.
Well, this has been
really fascinating,
and we do appreciate
you joining us today.
So a big round of applause
for Theresa Payton.
THERESA PAYTON:
Thank you, everybody.
HOST: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]